A mysterious sex box, a 150 year long dream,
and so many time loops. These sci-fi movies
still have audiences scratching their heads.
Stanley Kubrick's "2001: A Space
Odyssey" is considered one of the
great sci-fi classics — and one
of the most revered works in film
history. The 1968 picture pushed
the boundaries of special effects,
lifted sci-fi from B-movie shlock to serious art,
and made everyone afraid of killer computers.
After escaping the clutches of Hal 9000,
astronaut Dave Bowman is sucked into a trippy
tunnel right outside Jupiter. He's assaulted
with all sorts of lights and crazy colors
before winding up in a cold, soulless hotel room.
In just a matter of minutes, Bowman turns into
an old man — and that's when a black monolith
appears at the foot of his bed. These monoliths
have been turning up the entire movie, sparking
new stages of evolution whenever they appear.
When Dave reaches out to the big black
obelisk, he turns into a glowing space fetus.
This magical floating baby is known as the
Star Child, and in the film's final sequence,
it floats out into the galaxy, looking down
at Earth. Did Dave literally transform into
an alien infant? Is the Star Child symbolic
of humanity's next stage in evolution?
Could it mean something else altogether? It
doesn't seem like we'll ever know for sure.
"Its origin — and purpose
— still a total mystery."
"A.I. Artificial Intelligence" is a thoroughly
depressing affair. After all, this is the film
where Haley Joel Osment breaks down crying because
his "mom" abandoned him in the woods. Granted,
Osment is playing a lifelike android named David,
but still, you can't just toss a heartbroken
"mecha" into the wild. After all, the world is
cruel to little androids. Poor David is bullied by
human kids, sees his fellow robots ripped apart,
and eventually finds himself stuck at the bottom
of the ocean, desperately wishing he could become
a real boy. It's a wish that will never come true.
And then there's that ending.
After two thousand years of solitude, David is
rescued by evolved A.I. The creatures take pity
on the little mecha, and using advanced tech,
they give David one last day with his mother.
That's how the movie ends: with David cuddling
his mom, happy at last. Some casual viewers
had no problem with the ending, but many sci-fi
fans were outraged at the shift in tone, placing
the blame squarely on director Steven Spielberg.
"A.I." was originally a Stanley Kubrick project,
so many assumed Spielberg screwed up Kubrick's
dark project by tacking on the sappy finale.
As Spielberg eventually pointed out, however, the
whole "David gets to spend one last day with his
mother" thing was actually Kubrick's idea.
More importantly, it isn't a happy ending:
the evolved mechas are granting David's wish
because they're about to shut him down forever.
They're going to kill this little kid, and
we're watching his final hallucination before
he's put down. If that's not a Kubrick
ending, then we don't know what is.
Richard Kelly's cult classic "Donnie Darko" hit
theaters in 2001, but fans are still trying to
solve this incredibly complex sci-fi flick to
this day. The plot follows the titular Donnie,
an angsty high schooler who narrowly avoids death
by a falling jet engine thanks to a six-foot-tall
rabbit named Frank. If that isn't crazy enough,
the film soon introduces the concepts of time
travel and alternate dimensions, turning a
coming-of-age tale into a cryptic head-scratcher.
"You're weird."
"Sorry."
"No, that was a compliment."
There's a lot of questions raised by "Donnie
Darko" that you probably won't see the answers to
on your first viewing. We know Donnie has to stop
an apocalypse, but what exactly does that have to
do with wormholes? How do deceased characters come
back to life, what's up with that demonic bunny,
and why is Donnie wearing that stupid
human suit? It's all so complicated that
Kelly felt the need to release a Director's
Cut to help fans put the pieces together.
"Donnie Darko" is a movie that demands
rewatch after rewatch, and while it's
possible to gain a decent understanding of the
plot, there's no denying that it's a mad movie.
Before introducing the world to
the Cheddar Goblin in his 2018 film
"Mandy," director Panos Cosmatos broke onto the
cinematic scene with "Beyond the Black Rainbow."
This psychedelic nightmare of a movie features
a telekinetic girl and a slasher scientist
who find themselves in a battle of life and
death. It's been compared to films like "El Topo"
and "Eraserhead" — and according to its creator,
the film's screenplay is only 11 pages long.
As you might expect, this is a movie that
takes its sweet time, drowning audiences with
surreal images and sounds that make you wonder if
you're watching a film or going on an acid trip.
The movie prompts so many questions: what's
really happening at the Arboria Institute?
What's up with that glowing crystal? And what
exactly happens to the villainous Dr. Nyle after
he goes beyond the black rainbow? By the time you
come down from this incredibly disturbing trip,
you'll either immediately want more, or
you'll have completely lost your mind.
Ex Machina is a creepy film that examines what
might happen when humanity finally creates
artificial intelligence. And what might happen?
Nothing good. That's a lesson that Caleb learns
the hard way after he's invited to participate
in an advanced Turing test by billionaire tech
genius Nathan. The programming prodigy wants
Caleb to see if his imprisoned android,
an A.I. named Ava, is capable
of independent thought.
The only hitch is that Ava looks like Alicia
Vikander, and Caleb starts to fall for her.
"You're impressed."
"Haha! Yes, yes. Heh. Although—"
"'Although?' He he he. There's a
qualification to you being impressed?"
Ava and Caleb seem to grow close, and after
realizing Nathan is a monster who's creating
female androids for his own sick gratification,
Caleb decides to break Ava loose. He hopes they
can run away together, and Ava seems totally
cool with Caleb's plan… but once she's free,
she kills Nathan and locks up Caleb,
leaving him to die as she sets out into
the real world. Her decision left a lot of
viewers baffled: why kill such a nice guy?
Well, Caleb might not have been
as glaringly evil as Nathan,
but he only treats Ava like a human
once he starts falling in love with her.
Even though he's more polite, he still views Ava
like an object in the same way that Nathan does.
He only decides to help her escape after Ava
flirts with him and makes him feel special.
Meanwhile, she's tired of being a slave, so
it's time for her to finally take control.
Directed by Christopher Nolan, "Inception" is
a bizarre blockbuster where cities fold on top
of themselves, trains appear out of nowhere,
and hotels spin around like crashing cars.
In other words, it's a movie about the power
of dreams. "Inception" takes place in the
subconscious, where rules can be bent and
mental barriers manipulated — but for all
its incredible imagery, the film sparked so much
conversation because of a simple spinning top.
The plot of this sci-fi epic follows a group
of thieves, led by the enigmatic Dominick
Cobb, as they try to implant an idea
in the mind of a young business heir.
If Cobb can complete the mission, he'll have
his murky past erased, and he'll finally get
to return to the U.S. and see his kids again. And
wouldn't you know it? The mission is a success,
and in the film's final moments, Cobb
is reunited with his children... maybe.
There's actually a good chance that Cobb might
be asleep — stuck in limbo for the rest of his
life. Everything depends on that infamous top:
if Cobb is in the real world, it will topple
over eventually — but if he's still asleep,
it will keep on spinning forever. The movie
cuts right as the top starts to wobble, which
resulted in endless debate about Cobb's fate.
According to Christopher Nolan, however, it's
not such a big deal if the top falls over or not.
As the director explained, the important thing for
Cobb is that he's back with his kids. Whether this
is reality or it's all in his head, the only
thing that matters is that it's real for him.
Finding love is hard enough, but if you've only
got 45 days to find a mate or be morphed into an
animal, that makes things a lot more difficult.
Unfortunately for poor David, if he doesn't find
a partner in a few weeks, he'll be tossed into
a mysterious machine and turned into a lobster.
However, things start looking up when he
meets the Shortsighted Woman. In this society,
partners have to share a physical similarity,
and since they both suffer from vision problems,
it seems they're a match... until she is blinded.
This leaves the lovers in a tricky situation:
if they want to make this work,
David will have to blind himself too.
"I'm going to do it with a knife."
"Do you want me to come with you?"
"I'd rather you didn't."
As the Shortsighted Woman waits at a diner booth,
David stands in front of the bathroom mirror,
with a steak knife just centimeters from his
own eyeball. Before we can see anything, though,
the film cuts to the Shortsighted Woman
sitting at her table. She waits and waits for
David to return, but the film goes black before
audiences can learn if David did the bloody deed.
Not even the cast and crew of "The Lobster" know
the truth. Speaking with Entertainment Weekly,
Colin Farrell revealed that director Yorgos
Lanthimos [YOR-gohs LAN-thih-mohs] and
screenwriter Efthymis Filippou [EF-thee-mis
fih-LEE-poh] never came up with an answer for
the film's ending. As for himself, Farrell
can see it going either way. He joked:
"Honest to God, part of me thinks he does it.
Then part of me thinks that when the camera cuts
back to Rachel Weisz, I'm already in a f---ing
Uber, heading down the road as fast as I can."
The actor also raised the possibility
that David could have faked blindness,
so he could be with his lover while still
maintaining his eyesight. Whatever your
interpretation might be, it probably says
a lot about the way you view romance.
Written, directed by, and starring
Justin Benson and Aaron Moorhead,
2017's "The Endless" follows two brothers who
escaped a UFO cult when they were younger,
but are lured back by a strange video tape.
Once they arrive, freaky things start happening,
and they start to get the feeling that
there's something evil hiding in the darkness.
By the time the credits roll, "The Endless"
has posed a lot of complicated questions.
What's up with the entity and the time
loops? What's with those freaky statues?
And why is there a crossover with
Benson and Moorhead's earlier movie,
"Resolution?" Well, the invisible demon
haunting our heroes is a stand-in for
horror movie audiences who like their stories
to have dark endings. And as it turns out,
the creature drew the brothers back to the cult
in hopes of trapping them in a time loop. This
particular desert is crowded with different loops,
some which last seconds and others which stretch
on for decades. If you die in the loop or submit
yourself to the beast, you'll be trapped forever.
That's why the cult members look so young:
they've been repeating the same cycle every
ten years. At the end of each loop, the entity
tears them to shreds, and they start over again.
It's all part of the creature's need
for scary stories with violent endings.
It turns out that the guys from "Resolution"
are stuck in a time loop of their own,
a revelation that adds new depth to the 2012 film.
As for those monuments? They all represent
the evil entity. They were constructed by
the victims stuck in the loops, and they're meant
to express how these poor souls viewed the demon.
Judging by the apparent age
of some of these sculptures,
it seems like this inter-dimensional creature
has been trapping people for a very long time.
Christopher Nolan's 2020 sci-fi flick "Tenet"
just might be the filmmaker's most confusing
movie yet. Met with lukewarm reception by
critics, "Tenet" is a high-concept puzzle
box that's more interested in giving the
viewer clues to solve it rather than answers.
"The hell happened here?"
"It hasn't happened yet."
The Protagonist is a CIA agent, who finds a
mysterious artifact during a mission. When
the artifact is stolen from him, he's recruited
by a time-traveling organization called Tenet
to retrieve it. The Protagonist and his handler
Neil travel the globe to recover the artifact, but
nothing — and no one — is as it seems. That sounds
straightforward enough, but things are never
so simple in a Christopher Nolan movie, and the
ending of "Tenet" is one of his most confounding.
The film's core narrative centers
around the concept of "time inversion."
That means the entropy of objects
from the future can move backwards,
so things from the future can get brought into
the past. Those in the present move forward,
while the future moves backwards — at
least, in the present. To achieve this
effect of two opposite movements at the
same time, Nolan shot the time inversion
action sequences twice — one normally, and
the other with the actors moving backwards.
Getting your head around the concept of time
inversion is the first key to unlocking the
rest of "Tenet." Most viewers are bound
to get lost their first time around,
as the movie breaks down linear time
to render it a circle. That's why even
the movie's biggest defenders say it takes
another trip around to really get it to click.
Whether it's the sight of a skeletal bear or a
man turned into a fungus, "Annihilation" is a
movie that sticks in your mind — but even more
compelling than the gigantic sharkagator is the
film's ambiguous ending. After heading deep into
the Shimmer — an ever-growing electromagnetic wave
that mixes and matches DNA — biology professor
Lena encounters a metallic humanoid that tries to
copy her likeness. Using a grenade, Lena kills
the doppelgänger and burns down the Shimmer,
but while she's saved the world, that doesn't
mean it's smooth sailing for our hero.
Lena's whole reason for heading into the Shimmer
was to discover what happened to her husband,
Kane. He's a soldier who went MIA after heading
into the world's freakiest light show — and then
a year later, he suddenly appeared out of nowhere,
deathly ill. Hoping to save his life and ease her
guilt, Lena accompanies four other women into the
Shimmer to figure out exactly what's going on.
What she learns is haunting: the Kane back at
the hospital is almost certainly a doppelgänger,
much like the one that tried to take Lena's place.
However, there's something odd about the Lena
who finally escapes the Shimmer. When she hugs
her clone husband, we see the color in her
eyes dance and wave, much like the lights in
the Shimmer. Did the real Lena make it back home,
or was she replaced by the doppelgänger somewhere
during their struggle? Or perhaps the Shimmer
altered her DNA and turned her into something new.
Whatever happened, Lena is a new person, forever
changed after literally confronting herself.
Inspired by the French short film "La
Jetée," Terry Gilliam brings a fresh
set of eyes to an old fashioned time travel
tale in "12 Monkeys." The killer cast and
gorgeous production design are enough to get
viewers to still return to this 1995 classic,
even if the ending is a bit mind-boggling.
In a post-apocalyptic 2035, James Cole is a
prison inmate sent back in time to stop the
virus that destroyed humanity. He travels back
to 1996 to track down the source of the virus,
but is continuously haunted by dreams of a little
boy seeing a man shot at an airport. In the end,
he finally catches up with Dr. Peters, who's
heading to an airport to start the virus outbreak.
Cole tries to stop the doctor and instead is
shot by the police. As it turns out, his dreams
weren't dreams at all. They were memories of his
younger self watching his future self get killed.
The purpose of Cole's tragic life is just one of
many questions left at the end of "12 Monkeys."
We never get to see if any of Cole's actions
change the timeline, but it's heavily implied
that his actions were fruitless. Nothing will
change. The past stays the same and the future
is unavoidable. The whole affair is a bleak take
on time travel that appreciates repeat viewings.
"The movie never changes, it… can't change, but
every time you see it, it seems
different because you were different."
"Stalker" is a classic, but by today's
standards, it's definitely a slow movie.
Watching Andrei Tarkovsky's 1979 cerebral
work of post-apocalyptic sci-fi is a test
of patience — but for those who have stuck with
it, the reward has been great. Over the years,
many people have watched this movie
and walked away with different stabs
at its meaning. A deeply interpretive film,
"Stalker" is as confounding as it is profound.
Based on Arkady and Boris Strugatsky's novella
"Roadside Picnic," three men
— the writer, the professor,
and the Stalker — go into the radioactive "Zone,"
which contains a mythical wish-granting room.
The trio ventures through a dangerous land of
paranormal anomalies and unexplained phenomena,
all while philosophically sparring with each other
and exploring their motivations for the journey.
When they finally reach the Room, however,
there is an inexplicable anti-climax,
as the three men sit in silence. What happens
inside the room and the significance of their
journey is left entirely ambiguous. What
exactly is the Zone, and how has it changed
the people who dare enter it? The final shots
of the movie show that the Stalker's daughter
has now gained superhuman powers, which
are implied to be a result of his journey.
This question and others are asked
from the very beginning of "Stalker,"
and its lack of answers still sparks
vigorous discussion over 40 years later.
"Predestination" is based off of Robert A.
Heinlein's 1959 science fiction short story
"All You Zombies." This 2014 sci-fi puzzle stars
Hawke as Agent Doe, a disfigured time-traveling
agent who moonlights as a barkeep after a failed
attempt to stop the bomber that wounded him.
One day in 1970, Agent Doe meets a man
called John, who reveals that he was
born an intersex female named Jane and had
a child, who was stolen by an unknown man.
Complications during birth led to forced gender
reassignment surgery, so Jane began living as
John. Agent Doe takes John back in time to 1963 to
get revenge on the man who created this situation,
only to realize that John is the person
who got Jane — himself — pregnant. So,
Agent Doe takes Jane's baby further back in
time to 1945, and the child grows up into Jane.
This is the predestination paradox, and it only
gets more complicated as the movie continues.
By the end, it is revealed the
movie is about a single character:
the agent and the bomber are also the
same person as John, Jane, and the baby.
"It's a paradox, right, but it
can't be para-doctored, heheheheh."
After learning who he will become, the agent
kills the bomber and tries to close his own loop.
That's where "Predestination" ends,
leaving us to imagine John's endless
nightmare and wonder about the logic
and existential questions behind it all.
Robert Pattinson fans might follow the dreamy
actor to the ends of the Earth, but apparently not
beyond our solar system. At least, that's how the
reaction to 2018's "High Life" would make it seem.
While many critics found Claire Denis' erotic
sci-fi drama mesmerizing and thought-provoking,
a majority of the audience seemed
to disagree. This is likely due to
the slow pacing and cryptic methods
of storytelling that Denis utilizes.
Monte is a criminal on death row, who's been
placed on a ship full of convicted killers heading
towards a black hole. He and the others are
subject to experiments run by the mysterious Dr.
Dibs, who controls sexual activity on the ship.
Monte manages to father a child, and he works to
keep himself and his baby alive amidst the intense
psychological pressure of Dr. Dibs' experiments.
"High Life" is focused on sex, but
many viewers are still unsure about
what exactly the movie has to say about
sexuality thanks to its dream-like quality.
Its most puzzling aspect is its representation
of "The Box," a room that the prisoners use to
stimulate themselves. Denis described herself
as "pro-sex" in an interview with Slate and
clarified that she sees The Box as something
positive. However, in an interview with GQ,
she also said that she herself doesn't actually
know what "High Life" is about, saying —
"I'm not interested in understanding,
honestly. It's not a joke,
I don't need to understand, I need to feel
good about something, that's all I need."
Although Cameron Crowe's 2001 sci-fi adventure
was a critical punchline in its day, "Vanilla
Sky" has gone on to gain a cult following.
This ambitious thriller is an English-language
remake of Alejandro Amenábar's "Open Your Eyes," a
trippy warning about the dangers of technology and
vanity. Narcissistic playboy David Aames is in a
horrific car accident after his jealous girlfriend
Julie discovers his relationship with another
woman, Sofia. After recovering, David rejoins
society and starts dating Sofia again, but his
reality starts to disintegrate in strange ways.
The ending of "Vanilla Sky" reveals that the
movie has taken place inside David's lucid
dream that has been going on for 150 years. After
disfiguring his face and losing Sofia in reality,
David opted to exist in a cryogenic hyper-sleep
inside a dream, where he can live a fantasy
life until the technology needed to repair his
face is perfected. His idealized fantasy world
gets ruined by a glitch in the system,
so David is given the choice to either
stay in the dream or leap off the roof to
break the illusion and return to reality.
"Look at us. I'm frozen and
you're dead. And I love you."
What David ultimately chooses and what it
represents is unclear. He decides to jump
and break free from this dream, but he doesn't
know for certain if he will wake up — or what the
world will even look like now after so much time.
In the final moments, we hear a woman's voice call
to him, but it's not clear whether he has made
it to reality or if he has finally passed away.
The bittersweet romantic drama "Eternal Sunshine
of the Spotless Mind" is a collaboration between
surrealism experts Charlie Kaufman and Michel
Gondry. When Joel and Clementine break up,
they both decide to undergo a procedure to
have their memories of each other erased.
The majority of the film takes place in Joel's
mind, as he recalls his doomed relationship with
Clementine as the memories get deleted. After
going through the procedure, he retains one
vague recollection of Clementine telling him
to meet her in Montauk, where they first met.
Despite the procedure's success, both lovers
find each other again in Montauk and start again,
even after learning the truth of their
chaotic and painful relationship.
This might seem to defeat the point
of the sci-fi elements — or even the
story as a whole — but it speaks to
the movie's central theme of love.
These two have a special connection,
and nothing can get in the way of that.
It's a hopeful ending, although seeing
the way Clementine and Joel's relationship
plays out makes one wonder if they're
doomed to repeat the same mistakes.
Should these two really be together? Or
is the love that was strong enough to
bring them back together also enough to break
their old dynamic? According to Vanity Fair,
Kaufman originally conceived of a darker ending,
in which Joel walks away after learning the truth.
Knowing that Gondry and Kaufman disagreed over
whether Joel and Clementine should end up together
further enhances the uncertainty of what
comes next for this eccentric couple.